Hello, PPOM1ers.
This is Dr. Gindi.
This is going
to be a series
of two lectures, one on
cold-related injuries and
hypothermia, and
the second one is
going to be about
hyperthermia.
And I do apologize
in advance that the
first one is a lot
longer than the second
one, and I hope not to
go over, but if I do
go over, then the reward
is that the second
one is shorter. So
let's get into it.
We're going to have
some objectives
that I hope to meet
during this talk.
We're going to talk
about the different
cold-related injuries,
going from the
milder trench foot
and chill blades to
the more serious
frostbite. We're
going to talk about
each one separately.
We're going to talk
about how to figure out
what stage of accidental
hypothermia a person
is in and how to
take care of them and
finally a little bit of
a morbid subject we're
going to talk about
know a lot of a morbid
subject we talked about
when do we feel is
justified to pronounce
someone dead and some of
the signs that justify
that let's talk about
the first one which
is a trench foot the
word trench foot the
term trench foot came
from the soldiers in
World War One who would
be standing in deep
puddles of water for really
long periods of time
and their feet got
swollen and macerated
and and and waterlogged
waterlogged is macerated
is a more scientific
way of saying waterlogged
the trench foot
can lead to peripheral
permanent nerve damage
and if you look at
the white part of this
person's feet the
it looks like the
pruning that you
experience when you're
in the shower a long
time. However, that
pruning is not the
same thing as trench
foot. It's not
really trench finger.
I don't think there
is such a thing.
The reason that we
prune when we're in the
shower is because
there is a sympathetic
response that causes the
skin to buckle up like
that. As a matter of
fact, if you have had
a sympathectomy of a
certain part of your
extremity, you'll be
unable to prune when you're
in the shower for a
long period of time.
So that's different
than trench foot. So
trench foot initially
looks mottled when you
take the shoes off
and the socks off, and
mottled means it's some
blue and some patches
of red and white, but it
can be also very pale,
meaning there's not
a lot of blood flow.
It can be anesthetic,
meaning there's no
sensation at all. It's
numb, and you may not
be able to feel a
pulse. But then once you
re-warm these extremities,
the people will
get extreme pain because
the blood will start
flowing in there and
the nerves will respond
and then the person
will feel the pain
so the inflow of blood
causes it to become
very red and then these
vessels are sometimes
damaged and more porous
and therefore the
fluid of in the
inter that intervast
intervascular space goes
into the extra vascular
space and you become
edematous this can lead
to some problems in
the future that may be
permanent anesthetic
you may not be able to
feel your feet ever
again there can be
paresthesias and paresthesias
meaning means and
if you like etymology
as i do it means next
to sensation asthesia
esthesia means feeling
and para means next
to so it's a feeling
next to the feeling
that you really have.
And so people describe
it as many different
types of things,
but one of the more
typical ones is
pins and needles or
electrical feeling. So
it's a sensation that
is sending signals to
your brain that isn't
really there.
There really isn't
electricity when you sleep
on your arm too long,
but it's a paresthesia
sending signals
to the brain that
there is electricity.
And I just wanted to
just do a little bit
of an aside where I
think we all need to
understand and appreciate
that patients sometimes
mean a certain thing
and we think they
and they mean something
different. And a
particular example that
I want to bring up
is the Spanish word
calambre. I think I
actually spelled it wrong.
Yeah, I did.
The A and the
M are switched.
I've heard a lot of
different Spanish
-speaking people use
this term and they mean
several different
things, which means it
doesn't really mean one
particular thing. I've
heard it used with
the description of
electricity feeling
I've heard it used for
describing a cramp
which is an invalid
voluntary spasm of a
muscle group and also
Charlie horse the feeling
that you get after
you've worked out
and your muscles are
sore so don't just accept
that you think that
a certain word means
what it means you
really have to know
what the patient means
dysesthesia is another
sensation that isn't
really there but it's
painful that's the DYS
prefix and hyperhidrosis
means that it'll
be sweating inappropriately
too much all the
time and you may be
extremely sensitive to
cold in the future
and it's possible even
for this to lead to
gangrene and necrosis and
required debridement
the treatment is pretty
straightforward dry
them up take the shoes
and socks that are
wet off put a loose
dressing on and wait
before you decide what's
going to be debrided
because you'd be surprised
that some tissue can
come back to life.
Chilblains, it's
also called perneo.
This is an exposure
to intermittent,
long-term, damp, non
-freezing conditions.
So it's not the
same as being in
water, but it
can be in damp
conditions. That's
why it's common in
the UK where it
rains all the time.
And it's more common in
people who experience
Raynaud's phenomenon.
Maybe some of
you have seen this or
experienced it yourself.
It's where one or
several of your
fingers, when it gets
cold out, will turn
blanching and white.
Maybe the other fingers
are red. And to be
distinguished from
Raynaud's syndrome,
which is an autoimmune
disease, but Raynaud's
phenomenon can happen
and nobody really
knows what causes it.
So early on, you can see
that you can get these
paresthesias
and dysesthesias
and anesthesia,
just like with
Trenchford. But
later, you get
pruritus, which
is itchiness, and
erythema, which is
from the inflow of
blood, and edematous,
very much like
Trenchford. And then
you can get cyanosis,
which is the tissue
looks bluish.
You can get afterwards
nodules and vesicles
and ulcerations forming
on the extremities.
and when you rewarm
these particular
patients you can get
these tender blue
nodules that can
persist for several days
and usually there's
no permanent damage
and the treatment is
supportive and the
one studies one study
has shown that if
you use nifedipine it
can help dilate the
blood vessels and get
more blood flow quicker
and can help with
the pain other meds
that have been Contride
or non-steroidals,
pentoxifiline,
which is a red cell
manipulator. It makes
red cells more malleable
and squishable and
deformable is the right
word to go through
vessels more easily.
And topical
steroids just to
decrease the
inflammatory response.
And none of them
have really been
shown to be
consistently effective.
paniculitis this is
something that is basically
it's kind of a
misnomer it's not
inflammation of the
fat paniculitis
means inflammation
it's actually
necrosis of the fat so
the fat below your
skin relies on adjacent
blood supply and when
it's deprived of the
blood supply for a
while because it's cold
and you have
vasoconstriction the fat dies
and when it dies it
leaves these unsightly
poor cosmetic effects
and there's really no
treatment for it a lot
of people who ride on
wet horses for a long
period of time can
experience that because
the part of your body
the thighs against
the horse is generally
a very fatty part of
the body and the fat
along the inside of
your thighs will necrose
cold urticaria just
what it sounds like it
is urticaria which is
hives that it's induced
by cold. It's interesting
that hives can
happen from actually
quite a number of things,
the most typical of
which is from an allergic
reaction. But also,
you can get heat
-induced urticaria. Stress
can cause urticaria.
Exercise, believe
it or not, can cause
urticaria. And autoimmune
phenomena can also
cause them and some
types of infections.
So sometimes you never
figure out what causes
hives and um sometimes
they just come
and go just as
mysteriously uh as as they
go is just as in as
mysteriously as they
as they came and with
cold anaphylaxis is
rare even though you
can get urticaria other
types of allergic um
manifestations are
extremely rare and
it is associated with
all those other atopic
types of things asthma
food allergies
environmental allergies
dermatographia, those
kinds of things are
associated with cold
urticaria. And the
treatment is the same
as most other urticaria.
Antihistamines help
you not itch so
much. Other things that
have been tried with
varying success,
leukotriene inhibitors.
Epinephrine does work
for cold urticaria
just as it works for
any other type of
urticaria, but choose
your patients wisely
because epinephrine
does have side effects
okay now the big one
that's the most severe
frostbite frostbite
has to happen when the
ambient temperature
is above freezing in
other words you can't
have it when the
temperature is above
freezing zero degrees
Celsius is the temperature
below which you
can get frostbite when
the skin gets below
that temperature so
factors that will help
that will make that
happen are obviously
if it's colder
than zero degrees
Celsius it's going to
potentially happen.
And the wind doesn't
make it colder, it
just makes it feel
colder because you're
losing more heat. So
when I was a kid I
used to think the
term windshield factor
was the windshield
factor. I used to think
that people would
get on the outside of
a windshield and
people would drive at a
certain miles per hour
and they'd say, yep,
it feels about 25
even though it's 32.
But it's not really a
crazy concept that I
had because what happens
is that you will lose
more heat. So if it's
below freezing, you
don't necessarily get
frostbite, but if it's
below freezing and
there's wind it'll have
you lose more heat
from your extremities
and therefore the chances
of getting frostbite
will be higher
obviously if you're not
wearing an insulation
that'll make it more likely
to happen and how
long you've been out
there's a certain amount
of blood flow that
you can keep up with
after a certain amount
of time you cannot
perfuse those extremities
and they start to get
cold and then you can
get frostbite and of
course there are all
different host factors
your own sympathetic
response whether you're
drunk whether you're
you have um volume
on board there's a
whole bunch of things
that can affect it
when you thaw frostbitten
extremities out
it starts with the
arachidonic acid cascade
this is a bad acid that
causes vasoconstriction
and when blood
vessels constrict it's
more likely for
platelets to aggregate on
the inside of those
vessels and you get
blood flowing very smoothly
because the platelets
are kind of blocking
the way so you
get sludging of what red
cells and white cells
and that leads to
blood clots and little
tiny blood clots
won't allow the distal
tissue to be perfused
and that's what we call
ischemia so later
later on when we have a
really bad frostbite
you can have pallor
pallor just means
you're not getting any
blood flow to that
extremity because it's it's
white there's no blood
in it and cyanosis
means it's blue cyan
is a is a blue color
and that means that the
blood is not getting
back to be reoxygenated
it's kind of just
hanging around because
it can't get back
past the clots and
it's deoxygenated and
that helps distinguish
this from the other
non-freezing injuries
like trench foot and
perneo because those
don't cause cyanosis.
And the worst part
of gangrene is
that you can get
necrosis and gangrene
and that might need
to be debrided.
So how do we take care
of people with frostbite?
Well, we want to re
-freeze, we want to
re-warm them as soon
as possible. But if
you're on top of a
mountain and you have
somebody who needs to
get down and be evacuated
and there's a chance
that they can refreeze,
then it's a bad idea
to warm them up if
there's any chance of
it being frozen again
because that is going
to lead to much worse
injury. So only when you're
in a safe environment
that there's no risk
of refreezing should
you start to warm
them up. And it's not
too complicated, You
just dip their extremity
in warm water between
37 and 39 degrees
Celsius until the area
is mushy and pliable
and you start to see
blood flow and redness.
Don't be chintzy
with the morphine.
This really,
really hurts.
And another thing
that is often
forgotten is that
frostbite is a tetanus
-prone wound. There
are many tetanus
prone wounds,
infected wounds,
puncture wounds,
devitalized wounds,
contaminated wounds.
Those wounds, you need
to think about the
person's tetanus
status, and if it's been
more than five years
since they've had a
booster, they need
to have a booster of
the active immunization.
If they've never
been immunized against
tetanus, they've
come from a country
maybe where they didn't
get it as a child,
then they need the
tetanus immune globulin
as well, the passive
immunization as well.
Don't forget that.
How do we take care of
the skin when someone
has experienced
frostbite? Well, these
are two things that
are sort of been found
to be non-controversial
because there is
literature that supports
them. If someone
has a blister, then
it's already ruptured.
Then it's okay to pick
away at the blister
that's broken because
that skin that's
over the broken
blister is dead. And it
is going to just be
a breeding ground for
bacteria. They're going
to use that as food
and they're going to
multiply quicker. So
if you have a
ruptured blister, you
definitely should take
off the blister. And
those substances that
are really bad inside
the blister, the
thromboxdain and the plastic
glandins, which are
bad for the tissue,
will also have a
better way to get out.
And also it allows
the application
of some topical
materials which will
eventually promote
epithelialization,
namely ointment
-like substances.
And those
ruptured blisters
should definitely
be cleaned up.
If the blister is
intact and there's blood
inside the blister,
in other words, a
hemorrhagic blister,
It's been shown in one
study that if you
do break these open,
things get worse. And
the only exception
being is if they're
so big that they're
limiting motion of
a joint, or if it's
extremely large, then
you should debride it.
There was one study
that showed that if
you stuck a needle
in it and aspirated,
that might help with
the healing process.
But that was
just one study.
Since I did this talk
last time, the literature
has become less
controversial about
using thrombolysis to
treat severe frostbite.
Now, thrombolysis comes
with its own
complications.
You're going to be
breaking apart a clot,
thrombolysis, and by
giving a thrombolytic
agents like alteplase,
streptokinase,
if you give them, those
are going to break
apart the existing
clots and hopefully
restore blood flow
and that's been shown
in these studies now
to be beneficial and
the recommendation
based upon the studies
is that it's 1c so
people who do this for
a living recommend
that you do it but
it's really not based
upon rock solid evidence
it's based upon
relatively weak evidence
but it's still
recommended to do it
because there's a
bunch of weak evidence.
So it's not going
to, nobody's going
to fault you if
you don't do it
because it's only
a recommendation.
The following are
controversial subjects
because there's either
not literature or
the literature itself
is controversial.
What do we do about
unruptured blisters?
Theoretically, those
blisters that are still
intact are still
sterile. They got the bad
stuff in there, the
thromboxane and the
prostaglandins, but at
least they're sterile.
So we have a balancing
act and we don't really
know what to do with
them. I usually leave
them alone and I
usually put a donut
dressing around it so
that'll support pressure
on the sides of it but
not putting any pressure
on the blister itself
you can do the same
thing with a foot
blister that is just from
having you know tight
hiking shoes it's
called moleskin you
just build up layers of
this cushiony material
with a central area
that's missing do we
give antibiotics plus
minus topicals all of
them have been shown to
have variable effects
but they all have
something in common.
They're gooey. And the
gooeyness is what's
thought to increase the
rate of epithelialization
of making new skin.
Steroids, always
controversial. I'm not
going to talk about
that too much more.
Sympathetic blockade.
Well, if the problem
is that you're not
getting blood flow, then
if you inhibit what
constricts blood vessels,
which is the sympathetic
nervous system,
the thought is that
you can get more blood
flow to the area. That's
pretty aggressive.
Medical, bupivacaine
is basically a long
-acting anesthetic
because this hurts
a lot. And so they're
going to be in
pain for a long time.
There's also a new
one called ropivacaine,
which has less
cardiotoxicity, but
they're both long
-acting 12 to 20 hours
long where you can
actually relieve
the pain completely.
Other things,
hyperbarics, if
you're not getting
enough blood,
enough oxygen.
So give more oxygen in
a hyperbolic chamber
literature is
controversial again heparin
that's an anticoagulant
but you've already
coagulated dextran which
is a volume expander
so if you give
more fluid in the
intravascular space it
could potentially wash the
bloodstream the blood
clots step further
downstream all these
are unproven this is
only a picture that
I've intended to show
you for the reason that
we delay debridement
until we really know
what's going on just
take a look at both
of the thumbs the
person's left thumb is
almost completely intact
and when you look at
what it looked like
before it looked like
he was gonna lose the
entire tip and then
the right thumb most
of it looks like it
was gone and they only
lost the tip so what
do we do with these
people well you know
if all things are being
cool they have good
follow-up and they're
trustworthy and you
can trust them to come
back and you have a
place to send them to,
there's a lot of ifs,
they can potentially
be discharged, you
know, if you can
get their pain under
control as well. And
if they do follow
up, there's no, like,
frostbite fellowship,
but the people
who handle this best
are ones who do burn
fellowships or plastic
surgery fellowships.
So let's talk
about hypothermia,
where the whole body
is cold, and the
definition is less than
35 degrees Celsius.
We're going to be
talking mostly about
primary hypothermia,
when the body temperature
is lower than it
should be because it's
cold outside. But
we're going to touch
upon some of the
secondary causes of
hypothermia, the medical
illnesses and the other
things that can make
you be colder than
you would have been,
only insofar as it's
going to make primary
hypothermia worse.
So these are the
causes of secondary
hypothermia. So we're not
talking about them much
in this lecture I'm
gonna breathe through
them so you can lose
a lot of heat when you
burn yourself you have
a large body surface
area that's burned
you lose that ability
to keep the water
inside of yourself so
the water evaporates
and the water evaporates
it takes heat with it
we often give people
cold fluids cold blood
cold fluid IV fluid
we sometimes cool
them too much when
they're too hot if
they're hyperthermic stay
tuned for the next
lecture, and we don't
insulate people who are
at risk of getting cold.
And being born is
a time where you're
going to lose a lot
of heat. Babies have a
high surface area to
volume. Remember, surface
area increases as
the square increases,
but volume increases
as the cube increases.
That's why animals in
the Arctic are big.
Polar bears are big.
Woolly mammoths are
big. Because the
surface area to volume
ratio is less. When
you're a tiny little
baby and you're
just born, it's the
opposite. So you lose
a lot more per volume
because you're born.
And you're also wet.
And you're not used to
being in an environment
that's colder than
your amniotic fluid.
Big one is, we're going
to talk about this
later in the talk, is
impaired thermogenesis.
The most important
thing that we do
is we shiver. That's
what creates a lot
of heat. And if you
inhibit that for
whatever reason, you're
not going to make the
heat that you need
to make to stay warm.
People who are very
old and very young,
they are at risk of not
being able to shiver.
People who are
malnourished so they
don't have the energy
stores to shiver and
being exhausted, same
kind of thing. Energy
stores are gone.
and people whose
muscles are not being
talked to by their nerves
appropriately to
tell the muscles what
to do will also have
trouble shivering.
There are other things
that cause secondary
hypothermia. Some of
them are what we do to
patients. We give
them medication. Other
people take medication
like xenobiotics, like
alcohol. Alcohol causes
vasodilation. You
lose a lot more heat
and also you're dumb
when you're intoxicated
or inebriated. You
don't know enough to
come in out of the cold.
Anesthetic agents,
same thing. You
don't know that
your extremities
are cold if you're
an anesthetic.
Opioids and sedatives,
same kind of
things. Vasodilators
cause you to
lose more heat. If
you're sending more
blood to the
peripheral of your
body, you're going
to lose more heat.
Interestingly,
that sepsis can cause
a temperature to
drop. That's very
interesting because in
elderly patients or
people who are cachectic
cachectic means wasted
away and malnourished
one of the criteria
for being in
sepsis is a low body
temperature and nobody
really knows why so
you can have a fever
or you can be very low
in your temperature
and that's one of
the criteria and
especially in the
elderly they'll sometimes
not have a fever but
their temperature
will be below 36 other
metabolic endocrine
disorders the one i
want to point out is
hypothyroidism. So
you've heard also
that if your thyroid
is low, you have
cold intolerance. You
want to always put
sweater on when
everyone else is warm.
And things that
can cause problems
with your hypothalamus,
which is the place
that regulates the
temperature. And all of
these disorders are
extremely rare. I'm
not going to talk more
about them. That's
because they're very,
very rare. And neurologic
lesions that can
affect a hypothalamus.
So you can have a
****** or a brain tumor
that affects the function
of the hypothalamus,
which is the part
of the brain that
regulates temperature
control. You can also
have a spinal cord
injury that can cause
autonomic dysreflexia.
So normally you will
do certain things
with your autonomic
nervous system such
as vasoconstrict the
periphery so you can send
more blood to the core
and you can't do that
when your autonomic
nervous system is not
working very well.
And shock and volume
loss and I'm sorry the
slide got cut off but
that basically says
volume loss from losing
blood. You just don't
have enough blood to
keep yourself warm.
Again shivering
is really really
important And if you
suppress the shivering
reflex with your
own medications,
analgesics or
sedatives, or even the
patient self
-medicated, then they
won't shiver, and
that's inappropriate.
You can exhaust the
energy, sure, so you
can be shivering for
a long period of time,
and now you don't have
any energy left, so
you stop shivering.
Also, we can put warm
devices on the outside
of a patient with
the intent to warm
them up. And then what
happens is they feel
warm, so they stop
shivering and they stop
making heat. So that
can be actually
counterproductive at times.
And then there's a
point at which there's
no return. After you've
reached 31 degrees
Celsius, you don't have
that shivering mechanism
intact any longer.
And that is why when
people are really,
really cold and we give
them things that make
them stop shivering,
it happens in
a variable way.
Therefore, to do
studies on patients, you
don't know if the
thing that you're doing
is making them worse
or if stopping making
them shiver is making
them worse. That's why
the literature is
kind of controversial.
This is not a Guinness.
This is an espresso soda.
So what happens to your
body when you're cold?
Well, first, as
mentioned, you increase
tone and you shiver.
So before you shiver,
you're trying to
get kind of tight.
And your muscles
are making
more heat that
way. And then
you're shivering
even more heat.
normally what happens
is you get peripherally
vasoconstricted this
is because the body
teleologically speaking
is trying to send
the blood where it's
more important which
is the organs the brain
the heart and away
from the skin which
needs it less because
that happens there's
this phenomenon called
cold diuresis the
blood vessels on the
outside of your skin that
are normally responsive
for losing heat
constrict so it loses
less heat and that
causes more blood flow to
the core organs the
most important one being
the kidneys and the
kidneys have more
blood flowing into them
and the kidneys say
oh must be volume
overloaded let me get rid
of some of this fluid
and that's called cold
diuresis and another
thing that makes you
pee more often not
just because you're
making more urine, but
your bladder muscles
contract earlier, which
makes you feel like
you have to pee with
the same volume of fluid
in the bladder. So
you have more fluid
in the bladder and an
urge to void earlier.
That makes you pee
very often in the cold.
Perhaps some of you
have experienced this.
This is a kind of a
spectrum of things
that go wrong with
your brain. It
can vary from
something as mild as
having impaired
judgment all the way
to amnesia, not
speaking clearly,
being uncoordinated,
being impaired in your
level of consciousness.
Your reflexes can go
away. But remember,
your reflexes can
go away not just
because you're cold,
but it could be that you
jumped off a building
and injured your
spinal cord and you're
in a pile of snow. and
so you think the
patient is just cold and
that's why they have
no reflexes when
really it is because
they just severed their
spinal cord. So be
careful that you think
only one thing is
wrong with a person.
There's a lot of things
you don't know that
may have happened to
lead them to be cold.
The EEG,
electroencephalograph, can show
their flat line but
they're really not
completely dead but
you may actually see a
flat line on their
EKG. Their pupils can
be fixed and dilated
which is usually a
sign that someone is
either dead or has a
medication on board
that doesn't allow the
pupils to constrict,
like atropine. But
remember, these all
could be reversible.
These can only be
temporary, and when
you warm them up,
they may come back.
Therefore, the old
adage, no one may be
declared dead until
they are warm and dead.
I read that this was
a study that supported
that notion in 2014.
But I remember learning
that same expression
in the mid to late
80s when I was in early
medical school. So
I don't know why
they're claiming this is
a new phenomenon or
a new discovery. So
basically what that
means is if a person
appears dead, you can't
declare them dead until
you've warmed them
up and they're still
dead. Then they're dead
okay so people can't
be declared dead when
they're still cold
all right this is a
weird thing paradoxical
and dressing being cold
makes you vasoconstrict
and shiver and after
a while you can't
do it anymore and so
you don't have any
ability to make more
heat and you don't have
any ability to
vasoconstrict because you've
got no more catecholamines
left and then
suddenly this big rush of
blood starts going back
away from the core
towards the periphery
and you feel warm you
may actually feel hot
and so people who died
in cold situations
all three of these
people started taking off
their clothes because
they all felt really
hot right before they
died this is an important
slide because the
person who wrote this
lecture namely me likes
to put these types
of questions on exam
so pay attention the
classic rhythm which is
classic and not always
happening, is slow
atrial fibrillation.
And you can notice that
this is irregularly
irregular, which is probably
atrial fibrillation.
It's slow. Now,
normally when you're
very, very slow and
you're not perfusing your
organs, that is an
indication for a pacemaker,
but not in this
situation. In this
situation, they don't
need to get more blood
because their heart
rate is too slow because
their metabolism is
low, so they need less
blood. And if you put
a pacemaker in, these
hearts are very irritable
when they're cold.
And if someone
isn't a pradycardic,
because they should
be when they're cold,
and if they're
tachycardic, something else
is going on. Maybe
they're losing blood
from bleeding, or
maybe they're septic,
or maybe they're
inebriated on some
substance, or intoxicated
on some poison.
so if someone's going
fast worry that there's
something else going
on also notice on
this EKG strip that
there's a shivering
artifact the wavy wavy
baseline is a real
indication that there's
a whole bunch of
things going on that's
not making you get a
good strip then there's
this classic thing
called the Osborne
wave at the end of the
QRS complex there's
this kind of big hump
with a very slow down
downward slope that's
called the Osborne
wave and also called
the J wave there are
other reasons for a J
wave and an Osborne
waves, but this is
something that in this
situation, you're going
to see that's very
almost pathognomonic.
You can see the
QT interval is
also prolonged.
And remember, the
heart is very
irritable. So don't
jostle them, handle
them gingerly.
Only start CPR when
they are in full
cardiac arrest, okay?
Because they can
go into cardiac
arrest from your CPR.
So what happens early
on is you increase
your metabolic
rate and then later
you don't have as
much of a metabolic
rate because the
temperature drops and
the cells sort of
need less metabolism.
So oxygen demand
goes down and that is
the theoretical reason
why you've heard
these stories about
people who are being
cold and wake up after
you know being re
-warmed because and
they're neurologically
intact, able to play
the piano because
their brain has been
protective because
they don't need
oxygen in their brain.
The brain cells are
sort of quiescent.
And this is the
hypothetical reason why
making people cold who
go into cardiac arrest
for other reasons is
supposed to have benefit.
And I'm not going
to get involved with
the huge controversy
over that. I thought
that there was a study
that was done that put
the nail on the
coffin, but apparently
there's still some people
doing this, which is
making people cold on
purpose when they've
experienced cardiac
arrest to save their
brain. We're not going
to talk about it any
more than that, because
it is controversial.
You can get rhabdomyolysis.
The muscle cells
can break down when
they're not being
fed. They can lice and
break down. And you
can also get pseudorigomortis.
So you've heard
of, you know, the
term for a dead person
is a stiff. That's
because after a certain
number of hours, all
the myosin ridges get
locked and you get
rigor mortis and when
a person freezes their
arms it's not rigor
mortis it's just that
their arms are frozen
they can still be
salvageable and the
rest of their body is
not frozen but just the
arms and legs are
frozen so be careful
about calling that rigor
mortis it's not and
the weird thing that
happens is that people
clot when the blood
not moving and the
platelets don't work
very well. So two things
happen. They clot
and they bleed. And
that's very similar to
DIC, which I don't know
if you learned about
yet, but you make a
lot of clots from all
different kinds of
reasons. Sepsis is a
very common reason to
get DIC. And then you
don't have any clotting
factors left, so you
start to bleed. So
you're bleeding and
you're clotting. very
difficult as you can
imagine to treat that.
Trauma patients come
in and they're stripped
of their clothes because
they want to make
sure we want to make
sure that they're not
got other injuries
that we that we can
potentially miss that
need to be taken care of.
So we do keep the
rooms warm and we we do
that often at the
expense of surgeons and I
like this photograph I
think it's a mash that
television show where
the nurse is blotting
this the the fire to
the surgeon because
it's so warm in the
room? Well, sometimes I
guess the staff don't
like to be that warm
and so they turn it
to temperature where
they're comfortable and
that makes the patient
cold. And when a person
is cold, they become
coagulopathic. And
that's a classic, classic
reason for people with
very severe trauma,
that and sepsis, for
them to die. They
just get clots in all
different vital organs
of their body, and so
watch for that in a
trauma patient because
they're usually *****.
Labs, again, none of
these labs are absolutely
indicated except
glucose is something
that definitely should
be done, especially
if they're altered in
their mental status
because they could be
altered because they've
been out and they're
out in the cold and
they have no more
nutrients, and so they
use up all their
glycogen stores, and they
could be hypoglycemic
Again, all it takes
is a little sugar to
get their metabolism
going again. So you
definitely should draw a
glucose. Other things,
if people have been
sitting around for a
while, their muscles
get broken down, they
can get rhabdomyolysis,
and a CPK will
help you figure out
whether that's happening
or not. Now, I want
to tell a quick story
because people like
stories. I took care of
a lady who was out of
shape, but she decided
to go to a spin
class, and she overdid
it, and five days later,
five days later,
she came to see me
because her thighs were
still hurting. So I
drew a CPK, and her CPK
was 25,000 five days
later. The actionable
level to admit somebody
to the hospital is
usually about 5,000
right after they've
injured their muscles.
And this lady, 25
,000 five days later.
And she did okay.
She didn't clog her
kidneys, which is the
thing you worry about
with throeptomiolysis,
that those breakdown
products of the muscle
will get caught in the
tubules of the kidney
and cause you to go
into renal failure.
Didn't happen
to her, but it
could have. That
was the most
impressive case
I've ever seen.
Electrolytes,
when you have cold
blood, the blood cells
lyse, and potassium
lives inside of
cells, so when
you lyse them, you
get hyperkalemic.
So be careful about
knowing what the
total load of any
particular electrolyte
is because you
have hemolysis.
And when you send a
sample of blood to the
lab and they report a
high potassium, they
can actually see
whether the blood cells
are lysed because the
supernatant will not
look clear. It'll look
more yellowish. And
then you should take
the reading with a grain
of salt because it
may not be accurate.
But if it's
hemolysis that's
happening in the
body, it is accurate.
Lactate, if you're
not perfusing your
organs, they go into
anaerobic metabolism.
and one of the
byproducts of aerobic
metabolism is elevated
lactate blood culture.
They could be septic
to begin with,
which is why
they didn't know
enough to come in
out of the cold,
or they could
become septic later.
So you want to see if
something's growing
in their blood. We talked
about thyroid causing
difficulty regulating
your temperature,
cortisol, ethanol.
Somebody has, you know,
someone's inebriated.
You should be careful
with relying on
an ethanol level because
you don't know what
the person's normal
ethanol level is.
I've seen people go
into a draw at 250, and
80 is considered legally
drunk. I would be
intubated if I had
a level of 250. I've
seen people walking
with an alcohol level of
500. So you can't
tell just by a level
that it makes sense why
they're not thinking
clearly based upon the
level. But you might
want to get it to
see if it's on board.
An osmolar gap might
be obtained because
people may have taken
some osmolarly active
substance like methanol
or ethylene glycol.
You can consider
getting a blood gas, but
remember the machine
rewarms the sample
and you don't know
if your lab corrected
for this rewarming
because blood gases
cannot be relied upon
when they're cold,
they're more
reliable when they're
warm, to tell you
what's exactly going on.
Coagulation factors,
again, the machine
rewarms the blood,
so you don't know
what's actually
happening in vivo, all
you know is what's
happening in vitro.
So how do we take care
of these people? Well,
that depends on the
core temperature. And
the word core comes
from the Latin, which
is the word for heart,
because what we care
most about is what
is the temperature of
the heart? That's the
most important thing.
And so in
French, it's cur.
In Spanish, it's corazon.
That's what we mean
by core temperature.
The best device to
measure someone's
temperature is
with a thermistor.
Regular thermometers
are not as accurate.
A thermistor is an
electrical device that
the resistance inside
the wire varies very
reliably with the
temperature outside the
wire. And if you need
to figure out what
someone's temperature
is in these situations,
you really do. you need
to use a thermistor
the temperature that's
best reflective of
what's going on in
the heart is one that
you put in the esophagus
that's right behind
the heart so it's
almost in the heart but
it's not it's just
right behind the heart
****** and bladder
are not really as good
as esophageal temperatures
how do we take
care of people in stage
one you've probably
all been in stage one
if you've gone you
know out for a day
skiing but basically you
put them back in a
warm environment you
take off wet clothes
you put dry clothes on,
you don't really need
to give them a hot
bath because that can
cause vasodilation
and actually make you
lose more heat and so
can the convective
currents of the water.
You want to give
them warm, sweet
drinks because
you need to
give them energy
to make calories
to make energy and
make heat. You want to
get them moving and
you don't really put a
thermistor in people
who are at this stage.
Stage two though,
this is where
you're starting
to get loopy. Your
consciousness is
impaired, and the
temperature is about
between 32 and 28.
The person may or
may not be shivering.
These are the people
that you want to actively
rewarm externally.
Warm blankets, those
chemical packs that
are hot. You can put
warm washcloths, warm
blankets. You might
want to put what we call
a bear hugger, which
is this big forced
air blanket that makes
you covered over with
warmth on the skin.
and you may consider
giving them minimally
invasive re-warming
techniques. So IV fluids
that are warmed,
that's kind of not too
invasive. And then
humidified oxygen also, if
it's warm humidified
oxygen, that's not too
invasive because you're
breathing anyway.
And bladder or nasogastric
irrigation with
warm fluids, I consider
that a little bit
invasive, but it's
considered minimally invasive
compared to some of
the other things that
we're going to be
talking about so you put
a Foley in the bladder
and you just put
warm water in the bladder
pull the the colder
urine back out and
just keep irrigating
with warm until until
the person responds or
you can put a tube
down the nose into the
stomach and do the same
thing use a thermistor
in these patients be
careful these are the
patients that can
get arrhythmias so do
want to not jostle them
take it easy with them
and you want to get
them all completely
covered in insulating
material and put them in
a horizontal position
so that blood can
flow to all the organs
evenly especially the
brain and remember other
things can be going
on stage three we're
getting much more
serious here so all the
things in stage two plus
the person may need
to be intubated they
may not need to be
intubated if they're
protecting their airway
that's a judgment call
but if you do need to
protect their airway,
you got them. That's
not as jostling as some
things that you
would otherwise do to
patients. So be gentle,
but do manage the airway
if they're not able
to protect it. And
because they're semi
-conscious or unconscious,
they cannot really
be fed. So keep them
NPO. NPO means nil per
aurum, which means don't
feed them because
if they aspirate the
food you gave them,
it's going to go right
down the airway
potentially. So remember, if
someone's unconscious,
you don't feed them.
What about treating
dysrhythmias?
If you see this
dysrhythmia on
EKG, I mentioned
that slow AFib is
the more common
one. And if you
want to give them
medications, so
let's say it's VTAC.
These medications
don't work at lower
temperatures like they do
at normal temperatures.
They get metabolized
a lot more slowly.
And so the
potential is if you
give them the normal
dose of medication,
when they finally
do get rewarmed,
you now,
let's say you gave
them medication and
they're cold and they
don't have a response,
so you give them more,
it's no response,
you give them more,
and then they get
warmed, then there's
potential to overdose
on those medicines
because they had
not been metabolized
when they were cold.
So if you're going
to give drugs,
again, drugs
themselves are usually
not, you know, the
best of answers. If
you're going to give
them, you want to
consider giving
them at lower doses.
Never increase the
dose, though. We don't
know how much that
decrease, though, should
be. That's why it's a
little controversial.
These people preferentially
should be brought
to an ECMO center. ECMO
means extracorporeal
membrane oxygenation,
where they
basically take all your
blood out, run it through
a warming machine,
and put it back in.
And cardiopulmonary
bypass does the same
kind of thing. Not
every hospital has
that. So if you don't
have that, you want
to use more invasive
techniques. We
talked about the
Foley and the NG tube.
Well, these are more
invasive. You're
going to put a chest
tube in and warm their
plural space. And
that's definitely
more invasive than a
Foley or an NG tube.
So people who would
benefit more are
those who really
can't tolerate these
conditions as much.
So those are the
ones who you
should have a lower
threshold to sending
to an ECMO center.
So especially when
people are having
these bad cardiac
rhythms that really are
not getting better
because you're
warming them externally
and because you're
giving them medication,
those are the
people who really
you should send them
as soon as possible
to an ECMO center.
This is the worst
stage. This is where
there's no blood
pressure, and no
pulse, and they're
very, very cold.
This is the only
indication to doing
CPR. When there's
no blood flow at
all, you got to move
some blood around.
You might consider
doing three doses
of epinephrine and
defibrillation if
they're in ventricular
fibrillation,
but don't give more
epinephrine than
three. And if they're
responding, though, So
maybe you'd consider
giving them more.
Of course, they need
to have their airway
managed for sure and
get them to an ECMO
center. And if ECMO
is not available,
you do the peritoneal
or pleural. I didn't
mention peritoneal
before, pleural I
mentioned. So you put
a chest tube in for
pleural to irrigate
their pleural space.
You put a tube in
their peritoneal
cavity to warm
space. That's also
pretty invasive.
So one thing that you
should consider is that
if you externally
warm them only when
you're transporting them
to the ECMO center, it
could potentially cause
them to peripherally
dilate and cause the
blood to go away from
the core and more
towards the periphery.
So if you're going to
rewarm the outside, you
have to rewarm the
inside too with those
more invasive techniques
on the way to ECMO.
Don't apply heat
to the head. I know
it makes kind of
sense to, you know,
you're worried about
the brain, so put
more heat on the
head. It doesn't work.
You want to get blood
to the whole body.
Things that we do
that maybe could
make things worse
is if you give
somebody sedative,
sometimes you have to
if they're squirming
around and not
allowing you to
take care of them,
But they can cause
vasodilatation,
and the risk
of benefit may
be worse than
the risk of harm.
And yeah, that's
how you should think
about it. The risk of
benefit, because it
may not benefit.
People always use the
term risk-benefit
as if risk something
that may happen and
benefit that's simply
something going to
definitely happen.
Don't think of
it that way.
People who are trying
to sell you things
want you to think
of it that way.
But you should always
think, what is the
possibility that this
is going to help,
and what is the
possibility that this
is going to harm?
And then weigh it.
vasopressors are
probably not going to
work because at
this stage persons
probably already
used up all their um
catecholamines and are
maximally vasoconstricted
uh but um it they
could potentially
help and if you're
going to use them
um in the stages
where you know their
all their own
catecholamines are gone you
want to use the ones
with beta effects meaning
the one that'll make
the heart pump harder
and not the ones with
alpha effects which
makes the periphery
constrict more. So
dobutamine is better than
norepinephrine. Those
are just examples.
And if you can use
central venous axis for
whatever reason, to give
them medications or
to give them fluids,
be careful about not
threading the catheter
all the way into the
right ventricle because
you can irritate them
and cause them to
go into a dysrhythmia.
So make sure the catheter
only goes into the
superior vena cava.
After drop. This is
a theoretical thing
that's not really
been shown to help to
happen too much at
all but it's something
that people talk about
and so you should
know what they mean
by that as you want
the periphery the
peripheral vessels
dilate and blood goes
away from the core
and it gets shunted
to the periphery away
from the core and
therefore the central
temperature drops so
it's a theory these
are bad things that
could potentially
make you say it is
time to call the code.
Potassium of 12 means
that there's been
so much lysis and
there's so much down
time that the cells
have just spilled
all the potassium
and that is a number
that's not really
compatible with life.
Obviously, if you've
re-warm them and
they're still not showing
any signs of forward
flow of blood by
ultrasound now, that's
a very good way of
telling, you don't
want to just put your
finger on the pulse,
you do need to get
a sonogram to see
that the heart is not
moving at all, to say
that there's no
forward flow of blood.
Consider,
I should have put
that at the end.
Yeah, actually I
did, but I just
didn't delete
it. So let's talk
about that next
bullet at the end.
Ultrasound shows no
forward flow of blood.
Therefore, if you
give vasopressors,
they're not going to
do anything because the
heart's not moving so
it doesn't matter how
much you constrict
the periphery or how
much you beat the heart
if it's not moving,
blood's not going to
flow obviously if they've
got a decapitation or
parts of their body
have already decomposed
those are signs that
there's a lot more than
just coldness going
on if someone was
witnessed to have a
normothermic arrest so
they clutch their chest
and then they fell down
in the snow and then
their friends found them
and they were really
cold, that's not a
good sign because
something bad happened
before they were actually
becoming cold. So
that's not a good thing.
Drowning is a bad
prognosis. And
yeah, the case reports
that you hear of
these little tiny
children who get
dunked in a very
cold river and they
come out alive
playing the piano,
they're case reports
because they're really,
really rare, but those
children have intact
diving reflexes,
meaning you get immersed
and you suddenly close
off your glottis and
that is a reflex that
not every person has but
you have it more as a
baby where you won't
get any water in your
lungs so your glottis
is closed off if your
whole entire body not
just an extremity is
frozen solid then that's
not a good thing so
the last thing I wanted
to say was that if none
of these things are
present and things are
looking like they're
potentially salvageable
and someone comes
in with hey doc no don't
don't resuscitate them
there's a DNR no
order in place this is
one where I would argue
with the family that
they're much more
likely to be salvageable
than if they went into
cardiac arrest because
of a heart attack so I
would say these people
have a better chance
of survival with good
neurological outcome
and if their dnr or dnr
order is in place that
you should probably
reconsider that that's
not an appropriate
time not to resuscitate
if they don't
have any of the other
bad stuff that i
mentioned above
and this is a great
movie the shining and
obviously he's frozen
solid and i look
forward to hearing
back about what you
thought of the lecture
and it was great
talking to you guys